I'm just saying I think that whole
situation might arise like here and I
don't think she dealt with that Kourtney
Kardashian hasn't exactly been on good
terms with her sisters yeah there was
the scratch heard around the world punch
you in your face so do it
and it's some seriously savage shade was
thrown I don't want a baby on her back
okay
I don't now in a sneak peek at the
upcoming episode of Keeping Up with the
Kardashians
kendall Jenner reveals her theory about
courts inner turmoil spoiler alert it
all traces back to court's ex Scott
Disick she has made up her mind in life
that she is taking on the victim role
like everything is somebody else yeah
and I just feel so bad because I don't
know how this happened I know how it
happens
tell me honestly I think starting with
their breakup I'm just saying I think
that whole situation might arise look
Jared I don't think she dealt with that
as for Scott he has his own take on
courts attitude I think Kourtney for a
very long time is felt really
misunderstood and a lot of people feel
like she's being rude but I know she
means well and you just got to see that
through her and it's kind of hard
sometimes but I do know that she wants
to be on good terms with everybody it
just doesn't always come out that way so
what happened next
Khloe sent an olive branch to our sister
via text we can't let this continue and
sweep it under the rug look we typically
do you're someone who I love and respect
and I want you to always feel good when
you're around me I would like for this
to be a conversation we're both in
capital letters sighs get to be heard I
don't want to feel like this is a
one-sided relationship whatever we can
do where the communication improves I
will do that courts response nine hours
later she sent me a video of the private
plane she was I don't think she's
extremely self-aware she can't sit back
and just be like are
I was wrong or like all right she can't
do that it's frustrating because I have
had such an amazing relationship with
portney and I would never throw that
away regardless if we're in a strange
place right now that's gonna come and go
but she's not even trying to make things
right of course all these theories
follow the season 18 premiere of the
family's reality show where Kourt made
it pretty clear she was obe are filming
see you filming you're completely fine
when we're not in this environment
actually so it should go through or what
I don't want to be I don't
[Music]
after the episode aired
Kourt dropped a bomb on Twitter saying
she quit the show and on Tuesday her
sister Kim confirmed it during a chat
with Jimmy Fallon on The Tonight Show
she's made the decision to take time off
now and I think she really needs it I
think that'll be so much better for her
Kourt hinted at all this drama during a
chat with et back in October you
mentioned that you might be ready to say
goodbye to Keeping Up with the
Kardashians where are you at on that um
I've just decided to spend more time as
a mom and you know put more of my energy
there and still but I'm not saying
goodbye
Brighton but I think you'll have to see
more of it on the new season season 18
just crazy isn't airing yet but it's
being filmed okay and currently do you
want in this room do you think the show
can continue going if you lose a sister
yeah I mean we definitely love portney
and we will miss Courtney and whatever
she decides to do but people come people
his family we are feel like it's a
revolving door so Kourt you might leave
this week she'll be back they all come
back
[Music]